cette victoire aujourd'hui des chiffres
des cas après avoir remporté le dernier
super bowl
laurent duverne est tardif ne sera pas
de la prochaine saison de football
américain les risques liés à la coved 19
perd 6 et le footballeur ne veut pas
devenir un vecteur potentiel de
transmission écrit-il surtout été pour
l'avoir connu depuis maintenant je
prends de 12 ans qu'on est très très
proche c'était une des décisions les
plus éduquées lui apprendre ces craintes
se faire et la bonne décision pour la
société en général qui peut juste pour 8
parce que c'est sûr qu'elle en tant
qu'athlète
qu'est-ce qu'on veut nous c'est pouvoir
pratiquer notre force et qui ma chérie
en aviron aussi mais derrière l'athlète
adoré il y a aussi le médecin et dans sa
publication laurent dubernais tardif
ajoute que s'il doit s'exposer à la kfw
il le fera en traitant des patients dont
ceux encore une fois très conséquent
ccsa cse son premier choix de faire une
carrière en médecine
une décision qui soulage aussi son père
tout en le rendant fier c'est évident
qu'ils aient un impact ce que vus en ch
et celle des lui a fait une certaine
prise de conscience par rapport à cette
décision aujourd'hui parcours plus fort
de la crise au québec il est allé prêter
main forte dans un chsct de la
montérégie elle a apporté du bonheur
dans un temps de 2 malheur selongey les
cours étaient sa chef d'unité elle n'a
que des bons mots il a à coeur le
bien-être de ses patients de ces
résidents comme il dit il a appris à
prendre le temps ch et celle du k1
hommes de valeur de très belles valeurs
d'authenticité puis de transparence des
valeurs qui ont pris le dessus
laurent du vernis tardive touchera 150
mille dollars plutôt que les deux
millions et demi prévu par son contrat
même son entraîneur a salué sa décision
à la boulangerie familiale de
saint-hilaire du client partisans aussi
se sont rangés derrière le numéro 76 de
tichy boycott le football mais qui
manque aux grandes écoles vous montrer
l'exemple par ce fonctionnement
donc tous les fans de football que pas
parce que tu es une vedette a gagné
super bons coups que tu vois l'encontre
des directives la pandémie issigeac
andré charbonneau radio canada mon frère